Garden City is it's an oasis I hope it's
what America becomes you'll find a lot
of people here that are willing to do
hard work they'll come in and they'll
sit down unwind
anyone can get their hair get here at
exclusive barber shop but only the best
work here
[Music]
to see a glimpse into the future of
america Modelo looks not to its coast
but to its heart it's there that we
found the hard-working community of
Garden City a place where people come
together to make a better life the
barber shops today are missing a whole
lot of of what it used to be where there
was the guys would come in they socially
connect the whole community he comes in
here and they all get along younger guys
listen to older guys and older guys
listen the younger guys ideas are
exchanged conversations happen I mean
that's that's what happens in here and
and everybody seems to enjoy that it was
just real fun to be here really I mean
there's so many different people that
come in here it's it's always
interesting there's always a
conversation that from somebody from
somewhere else I really enjoy that part
[Music]
trabajo Anita era post an amoeba mijo to
moyashi toda Mechanica the recent el
muro de trabajo in the square so
mail-order por que je man tango me
familia y lo que yo la diva me fever
contra bajo de jager a tener el guerrouj
every time I get a chance to I'm in the
studio try and do something make a noise
what I'm trying to work at is get my
name out there I want the world to know
my music where I came from my culture
you can trust each other when you know
each other if you want to know about
Garden City you read the newspaper when
you read the newspaper you see my
stories I'm willing to work past the
9:00 to 5:00 if I have to to cover these
stories because it's important to me and
the community
people working together here in Garden
City the spirit comes from you know just
trust and respect people from all over
the world have kind of unified together
to form a really nice town I believe we
all want our children to grow up better
than what we did and the best way for
that is to live peacefully amongst each
other I mean that's that's what I think
we could learn
[Music]